daddy just wants to eat you up hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to subnautica oh god so
creepy I'm wondering if the cave
openings always go to the same cave
system because that's pretty cool down
there but uh I have a number of things
that I need to do number one I need to
find out what these materials do number
two I need to find out the best way to
upgrade my seamoth which if I recall
correctly in my menu once I park this
bad boy and then hop back in my base
which I might do a lot to improve my
base because I like having a homely home
Jeffery and bubble butt okay so I have
little theam plasteel ultra strong
material so titanium ingot and lithium
would make plasteel which is something
um gold for an advanced wiring kit for
advanced construction just that and a
computer chip should do that so I just
need to get some some silver there huh
so what needs the plasteel is the
question because that could be a part of
WoW Dimond I have no idea how to do that
magnesium crash powder I don't know what
those are see Glide have that have that
I don't have a beacon current generator
convection current waterproof Locker and
grab a sphere okay so none of those
really affect me all that much but
there's got to be something in the
blueprint Oh modification station blue
train hello I'm at 96% with only two out
of three so I got to find another
modification station so that I can
upgrade my seem off and that'll allow me
to explore more in the deep depths and
also I need to figure out I'll probably
just gonna store the precious metals in
this one because there's no way that I'm
gonna be able to haul all of it with me
and keep exploring okay signal huh hmm
sorry I don't mean to sniff right into
the microphone I I'm totally unconscious
about that the rotten food I gotta get
rid of that okay so actually second
second thing I gotta do is I gotta get
some food because I am freaking starving
come here baby you Spadefish [ __ ] come
here don't run away from Daddy
daddy just wants to eat you up that's
so we're don't take that out of context
everybody I should I should really have
a filter before I start saying thing I'm
so sorry
I filled new fanfiction already you can
hear you can hear the tumblr eanes
typing away their laptops right now oh
and that's so funny
okay but anyway uh Ned in other news
okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
try to find a modification station so
that I can actually get what I need to
get this needs to go and dammit
okay I'll just drop it out in the middle
of the ocean that's all it means to me
and then maybe when I come back I'll
work about her ship sir I'll work about
uh getting more stuff for my base which
is oddly built in the middle of nowhere
and allows for almost no expansion
period uh that's besides the point so I
need to go find a modification station
which means that I need to go in the
direction that I have not gone before
which sounds like it might be this way
into the oh hey you know what I'm gonna
say hi to you cuz frankly I don't know
what you do oh god is that your face ah
oh god oh you're pulsating oh I'm gonna
Boop eeeh her boob Oh God that probably
wasn't the smartest of ideas well he
doesn't seem too bad he oh sorry excuse
me he seems kind of friendly or at least
friendly enough that he's not murdering
me right away huh no you're all right I
want to call you Sancho because I
remember a story I told I was probably
like strangled or something by a Sancho
ha Boop
sorry didn't mean it probably destroying
my friggin seamoth I'm gonna have to
build another one okay so I want to do I
need to get uh some materials from
around here because there's silver in
the red area that's like the first thing
I need and then I may explore the second
the second opening wherever the hell
be oh shut up Sancho I've got to do work
and I don't need you blasting your
bladders in my ear
all right well give me Scott give me
silver ooh hello you're exactly what a
Boston cannon that's a different kind of
candidate but that sounds cool I don't
know what a propulsion cannons gonna do
for me but it's probably gonna be okay
mm-hmm also I don't know how to tell you
guys this but I need to be rude for one
moment I need to oh god that's why it
was burping yellow liquid it was
literally broken I need to have a cough
drop while I'm playing this game which I
know is not pleasant for you guys cuz
you gotta listen to Dharma artha but
it's either that or I'm gonna be
coughing the entire time and it's not
gonna be fun so pardon my rudeness it's
just I I gotta do it I have nothing else
to do with my life okay silver okay
that's enough silver for now all right
so what I need to do is I need to find
more Pharrell oh that is so bizarre I
wonder if I just keep going out farther
and farther into the eternal dark abyss
which is getting night again because god
dammit I go to god you're everywhere
you're huge and everywhere it's so not
okay I have a hundred percent not okay
with that okay so I'm getting into more
I see something hello oh god it's the
odds the Jimbo jammers there like
defending the thing well they can't do
much to my seamoth I wonder if I can
just Ram them to death did they die oh
ha ha oh that did not do well for mine
okay where am I god it's so hard to see
which is up and which is down where'd it
go they knocked out my light
oh crap sickle oh I lost my light oh god
damn it damn and now I gotta go home I
got a dog this
[ __ ] I got a I gotta build that
repair thing god dingus dang it okay
I'll be right back whew hey whoa god
damn it ran right into a goddamn pillar
of rock god can't see a goddamn thing
that dark gas dang dang it thing what a
bunch of baloney what a piece of ass
[ __ ] yeah why don't you sing ass [ __ ]
online dick hole aren't you getting the
pole bagging cocking shove it up your
[ __ ] oh yes okay do it
welder magnesium and crash powder I
don't mean magnesium some salt deposit
okay salt deposit does that make sense
sodium sodium chloride oh just pull
magnesium right out of that [ __ ]
ha ha ha ha I have a new mission
everybody and it is whoa whoo ding dong
it is a fun mission I can't wait to go
on this mission whoo did it say welcome
Lord Cap'n I sure hope it did oh boy you
know my favorite creature in this entire
game the little buggers that gave me the
biggest scare of my life early on like
the first episode they're called crashes
and it's actually a plant according to
the game wiki and so what I need to do
is I need to find crash powder in the
plants after they come after me so I
gotta go into Anouk and cranny bait them
out and then go back in where there's
probably more that want to eat up my
face and steal their powder which is
great I can't wait to do this
Oh guys that one of them okay so I just
gotta go around till I find it it's
gotta be somewhere here little nook yeah
so hard to see I can't believe I lost
mine now Oh
oh hey okay so I can I can I can do it I
can do a flyby with my mmm-hmm it was
very manly sound ah did leave good to
get it
oh not yet hey yeah okay okay all right
come here you you you you you what where
do what that's what it said to do oh god
do I have to kill the actual thing you
wanna fight bro Oh God
oh that does not sound good hmm well
what does that do that doesn't help me
well this is stupid
how what that's what it said warning 30
seconds of oxygen remaining Oh what
happened where to go
did I do it Oh mmm well I thought that
was isn't it
emergency oh shut up
did you remaining well I mean okay am i
oh god okay give me a second okay so it
says it says that there's supposed to be
crash powder like in this thing after
they blow up which makes no sense cuz
that's not what it's not what I'm seeing
what is with this huh cuz it says the
strategy is make them blow up collect
the powder and then kill the thing and
this is killing in that way it won't be
there anymore but I need the crash
powder where the hell is it
dammit this is stupid
oh so weird not like someone else could
have come by and collect the crash
powder walls away are you anyway
geez what are you Oh what are you
alright well what are you doing whoa hey
what do you do
are you I have no idea what's happening
with this guy this guy is not okay
okey-dokey then something strange has
happened to my game methinks has had a
giant eye on its butt I think it's dead
I'm pretty sure I don't think that
things are working properly ready
warning thirty seconds of oxygen
remaining let me try a different area
hmm I mean I could just build another
seamoth but some diver rather not do
where I'm a whole bunch of lost I'm
trying my best to make this work but it
no wanna work with me so I say screw it
I'll make do without cuz if I can make
do without then I don't need it but it
is weird and it seems like if it might
be actually a bug and not just me being
stupid because I usually want to default
with the option that I'm being stupid
because I'm ready to admit that my own
intelligence is not sufficient enough to
be able to do what I want to do but I
think in this regard oh yeah I needed
salt
I am stupid good you do be do be dumb B
my name's not dumb B it's gonna be now I
need another one of these I am full up
on locker space alrighty then let's make
another
BAM okay so I got Jeffrey this one will
go to Billy even though my children
aren't welcome in my own home because I
hate them and I'm a terrible father I
shall name my things after them and also
bubble butt which is name of my ship
which I love more than my family ever
will deserve my love
do I have salt among these yes I do
one I do [ __ ] I don't even have the
modification Bowl blouse arrived
w-whatever
please spare those in their power
efficiency upgrade module I know I know
but I need the upgrade thingamabob a
Boomer to be able to do what I need to
done so let's go get it it's daytime
what am I wasting for Oh [ __ ] get out
of my way I got stuff to explore I've
got an ocean to discover I don't need a
lamp anymore because I've got the
unlimited potential of my own lust for
adventure let's go with that one man
this place is just swimming with those
buggers the evil buggers the one that
want to eat me eat them I mean I want to
eat a lot of things copper and only
copper and silver shut up
Sancho damn it
damnit I'm so terrible at everything I
do
alright keep an eye out everybody help
me out with this one keep an eye out
there's got to be some gas turn thing
under there it is
hi son how you doing I guess he was
happy to
what's a terraformer well I mean
obviously it's an earth former machine
that transforms the earth but that's not
the point
I'm a stupid redneck god damn it okay
keep an eye out everybody I'm not ending
this one until I find what I need
sorry fishy excuse my world I'm eight
too many strange creatures in aha sorry
hey whoa it's exactly what I needed oh
hey I got it I think okay that was quick
I guess I'm just too good my redneck
brain got too big and now I don't know
what I need to do I'm gonna get these
guys I need a couple of these buggers
come here get in my belly get in my
mouth and then my belly because that's
how biology works no no no no I know
your your scamper a good thing try
trying to bail me on your friend and
then run away you shan't fool me I don't
know he's tenacious I'll let him live it
Oh God
hey buddy hey buddy I forget what your
name was Greg NAR grognak the destroyer
I forget all right let's go home in
let's go home a slightly different way
so we might be able to find some more of
the modification things or the blueprint
what do you have it
oh that's not good
okay goodbye goodbye rue we go then
there's a whole series of crevices over
there just a whole bunch of nooks and
crannies mmm might as well explore
that's what this games all about right
exploring and then we find what I need
you found the salt caverns so long as I
can avoid being eaten by a horrible
monstrosity named Sancho whoa hey wait
am i God what happened what happened to
me oh I'm good
oh god oh man I hate the ocean hate the
ocean so much I'm going home screw this
[ __ ] this bull [ __ ] I'm out here except
for this salt and that's all but then
I'm out of here goddamn you [ __ ]
it's so stupid and I hate you yeah yeah
okay are we good now
okay we're good we can go home now I'll
pick this up too if never have too much
yeah it does please hey there's my
lovely home that I love more than my
children Geoffrey Billy Sam was that
Marshall ow why did my own ship run into
me god damn it
bubble butt how could you do this to me
your own father okay sorry
so we got enough materials that was a
lot of wandering around in that episode
but next episode we're gonna do some
stuff with our brains and thinking this
so thank you everybody so much for
watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video sorry
references oh yeah